[Music]
we see many of these logos every day and
we think that we know what they mean but
there are interesting stories behind
many of them and sometimes you'll find
out that even the designers didn't like
their own logos make sure you watch our
video until the end to see which logo
costs $35 and which logo cost 1 million
dollars if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 most misunderstood logos Apple you
have probably heard about the story
behind the Apple logo Allen touring with
a mathematician and scientist who worked
on the development of computers in the
50s unfortunately homosexuality was
against the law at that time and people
discovered that touring was in a
relationship with a man this is why he
was treated with estrogen injections
because people believed it that it would
cure his homosexuality he also ended up
behind bars and was not recognized for
his work to end his suffering Alan
Turing bit into an apple full of cyanide
and this is where people believe that
the Apple logo comes from the fruit with
a bite taken out of it is an homage to
this man and the rainbow represents the
LGBT community however you might be
surprised that this story is nothing but
a myth do you want to know the real
story behind the logo the Apple actually
represents knowledge and the reason why
there is a bite taken out of it is only
for scale Rob Janne off the man who
designed the logo wanted to make sure
that people would understand that it is
an apple and not another fruit like a
cherry or a tomato but don't you think
that the myth is much more interesting
even janap says that he's charmed by the
links that his logo has to this tragic
story Ferrari you will probably
recognize the horse on the logo of this
Italian sports car manufacturer many of
us would think that it represents horse
power used to measure the power of an
engine but we would be wrong there's
actually a much more interesting story
to explain why Ferrari is associated
with the horse the story starts with
count Francesco Baracca
a heroic pilot in the first world war
when a horse painted on the side of his
plane unfortunately the man passed away
during the conflict this was when his
mother had the idea to meet Enzo Ferrari
the founder of the brand she explained
what happened to her son and told him
that he should use a picture of a horse
on his cars believing that it would
bring him good luck and she was right to
think so because Ferrari is still one of
the most popular brands nowadays
originally the horse was read on a white
cloud background but Ferrari decided to
make the horse black in omage to
Francesco and made the background yellow
to represent the city where he used to
live he also added the colors green
white and red
represent Italy this is how he created a
logo that doesn't only inspire drive and
energy but also has a beautiful meaning
and this is a tale that Enzo told just
once so you want to make sure to
remember it Android we can recognize
this little green robot no matter where
we go but could you believe that he was
misunderstood by his own creator arena
block working as a designer at Google
she and her team were asked to create a
logo involving a robot that anyone could
identify so block studied science
fiction and came up with this idea
inspired by the pictogram of men and
women that we can see on restroom doors
with her colleague she also agreed that
the logo would be open sourced meaning
that everyone in the world could
customize it any way they want as most
companies defend their trademark with
lawsuits she said that it was daring to
let anyone use their logo for free but
we love the idea and think that it's
really fun to reimagine the logo as
different characters however Irina was
disappointed by the logo that she
created she said that the open-source
gave the little robot a life of his own
when she was in a movie theater the
little robot appeared on the screen and
her daughter yelled that her mommy
invented this funny character everyone
turned to look at her and Arina felt
embarrassed to be the one behind the
logo and we don't understand why we
think that the Android logo is really
cute and she should be proud of her
creation monster people have different
opinions on energy drinks some people
think that it's unhealthy and others
can't keep themselves from drinking it
so they just ignore this fact however
there is one woman who thinks that the
drink is actually hiding something evil
she believes that the drink conceals
satanic imagery and this is an example
of how clever the devil is if you can't
see what's wrong with the monster energy
drink you are not alone this is why
we'll let this woman explain what she
thinks she thinks that the letter n is
actually made of a Hebrew symbol the
letter Bob that is also the number six
when you put three of these symbols
together it makes the number 666 which
is associated with the devil she also
thinks that the slogan unleash the beast
is associated with the devil as he can
be portrayed in the Bible but what
shocked her the most is the cross in the
letter O she is still wondering what the
Christ has to do with it and we are
still wondering why she is asking
herself so many questions with more than
2 million views in less than 24 hours on
her video we think that this crazy story
gave a lot of attention to the brand
unfortunately it is not available
anymore so this woman won't be able to
save the world from this monster NASA
the National Aeronautics and Space
Administration is a serious independent
agency so we think that their logo would
be serious
- but over the years it just keeps
having funny nicknames the official
insignia is probably the best known logo
of the NASA in this symbol you can see
the stars representing the space the
circle representing a planet the red
vector representing Aeronautics and the
circular orbit representing space travel
the colors can also be associated with
the flag of the United States of America
it seems like James Motor Ellie did
everything right when he designed the
logo in 1959
NASA's second year unfortunately people
started making fun of the logo by
calling it the meatball it was used for
more than 15 years but in 1975 NASA
tried something more modern this was
when they created a new logo consisting
of the word NASA with a unique type
style they probably thought that no one
would see anything wrong with this logo
but many people made fun of it again
they nicknamed it the worm this new logo
lasted for a couple of years until it
retired in 1992 and the organization
decided to use the famous meatball again
no matter how people call it they are
now probably proud of these funny
nicknames as they are not shy to use it
on their official website Lacoste what
does a crocodile have to do with a brand
of clothes that doesn't even use the
skin of any reptile if you have been
wondering why there was an animal on one
of your favorite shirt you'll have to
listen to this story in Boston in 1923
Rene Lacoste was walking down the street
with his tennis team captain Alan Moore
this is when he saw a beautiful
crocodile suitcase in a stores window
display as they were getting ready for a
game that afternoon they bet that it
will cost won the match more would give
him the suitcase that he want the owner
of the brand did his best
but unfortunately lost and didn't get
the suitcase but a journalist George
Karan's heard the story and decided to
make a fun joke about it in his article
he said that even though Lacoste didn't
win he fought like a crocodile since
that day it became his nickname and it
is still associated with the power and
persistence of his game just because you
lose doesn't mean you can't win in
another way what cost me the best of
this failure to turn it into his best
looking success so if you're getting
ready for a tennis match make sure you
wear your favorite shirt and be inspired
to fight like a crocodile whether you
win or not
BMW you've probably seen this logo
before but did you know what it actually
means many people think that it
represents a propeller blade set against
a blue sky as Bavarian motor works used
to build aircraft engines in the 20th
century this theory would make sense it
could be a way to represent the origin
of the brand with the real story behind
this logo is actually much simpler when
journalist Steven Williams for the New
York Times visited German car music
he heard the real reason why the logo of
BMW is blue and white just to make sure
that his tour guide was right he decided
to call BMW North America the spokesman
of the company answered that the shape
and configuration of the roundel was
meant to replicate a spinning propeller
against a blue sky background everything
would make us think that the tour guide
was wrong but Williams decided to ask
more questions
another spokesman from the company
called to tell him the truth he said
that people working at BMW themselves
used to think that it was a propeller
against a blue sky because of a 1929
advertisement but they found out
recently that it actually represents the
colours of the Bavarian Free State this
is the proof that you should always take
the time to ask as many questions as you
want sometimes this is how you find out
that one person was right while all the
others were wrong uber the logo of this
company used to be really simple the
letter U was enough for us to associate
it with the name of the brand but
recently uber changed its logo and
people were disappointed they say that
it represents bits and atoms we couldn't
think of a worse way to make a logo
stand out if there are bits and atoms
everywhere around us there is no way
anyone is going to associate it with
this kind of service many people thought
that uber just failed to distinguish
their company from everything else with
this logo but they have a better
explanation uber used to be a way to
summon black cars and this is why a red
magnet represented the company at that
time then they changed it to a black
logo with the letter U to represent that
everyone could be a private driver but
nowadays uber does pretty much
everything you can do with the car it is
not only used as a transportation
service but drivers can also deliver
food to your home as the company keeps
changing they want to show that they can
do anything
bits and atoms might be everywhere but
so is uber when we think of it this way
the logo isn't so bad after all
we already got used to it anyway Nike
this is one of the best-known logos in
the world the company doesn't even need
to add their name in the logo anymore as
the swoosh is enough for people to
recognize the brand but at first the
logo wasn't really appreciated and it
was actually so cheap that even you
could buy many logos like that in 1971
bill Knight decided to make his own
shoes this was when he started his
company that we now all know as Nike
however it didn't have a name at that
time neither a logo this was when he
decided to ask a student at the
University where he was working to help
him the lucky one was Carolyn Davidson a
graphic design student she couldn't
afford a painting class so he approached
her and asked if she would like to do
some freelance work for his company
they agreed on the amount of money that
she would be paid for designing the logo
she showed Knight a handful of designs
and he didn't like any of them but the
swoosh wasn't so bad he really did say
that he didn't love the swoosh but maybe
it will grow on him it is crazy to think
that Phil Knight didn't even like his
own logo and do you want to know how
much Davidson was paid the student
received only $35 for her work Pepsi in
2009 the soft drink company spent 1
million dollars to create a new logo and
we can't believe that the result was
simply this the logo looked like the one
we saw before but with a little
different wave however the designers
believe that there are many reasons why
we should love this new logo our nel
group is responsible for this expensive
symbol they said that going back to the
roots moves the brand forward as it
changes the trajectory of the future
then they started talking about a lot of
scientific things like the golden ratio
according to them these proportions are
universally and aesthetically pleasing
they think that the golden ratio plays
an essential role in human perception of
beauty in their PDF document that takes
too much time to download
they also associated the logo with the
Parthenon the Mona Lisa Hindu traditions
numerical harmony Descartes and much
more they also talked about the energy
fields imbalance the Sun radiation and
the Earth's gravitational field even
though we don't really know what it
means it looks like our nel group was
just looking for a lot of reasons to
make that logo worth 1 million dollars
if it's scientific it must be true right
we don't think so
were you surprised to hear any of these
stories behind the most famous logos
don't be shy to tell us which one you
prefer we love to hear what you think
and that's it for 10 most misunderstood
logos if you want to see more stories
like this make sure you watch 15 secret
messages in famous logos thanks for
watching
[Music]